alors oui c'est accidentogène parce
qu'en fait on a des toutes petites
voiles et du coup on acquiert beaucoup
de vitesse on est à peu près à 150 km
heure sur trajectoire donc en fait on
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
on doit toucher l'eau donc là on est
plus à 150 kilomètres heure mais on est
à 130-140 touché loi 130 kilomètres
heure si on se rate de 1 m on peut taper
fort l'eau et du coup a ricoché ou et du
coup se blesser quoi et après même vous
avez vu on va à plus de 100 mètres après
avoir touché l'eau et du coup même ça on
est quand même à des vitesses qui vont
ça diminue la vitesse mais peut toucher
encore assez fort le sol quoi donc c'est
vrai que c'est accidentogène après c'est
une discipline qui demande beaucoup
d'expérience il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de place pour les débutants
alors on a tous plusieurs milliers de
sauts voire dizaines de milliers de
sauts ce qui me permet de pouvoir faire
une discipline assez particulière à ces
techniques